ah
[Música]
yo quiero ubicarlos en venecia en el año
1500 96
en el año mil 596 williams exhibe había
terminado de escribir el mercader de
venecia y en el alto tres por sea ibas
año que son dos de los personajes
principales de la obra se encuentran
cerca del marcador y alto y detrás de
ellos suena una canción yo me libre de
los lentes así que me acercan
dime dónde nace el amor es en la cabeza
o en el corazón responde responde
hoy estamos en el año 2018 y es la gran
pregunta que todos nos hacemos que nos
gobiernan corazón o cerebro
yo por casi 22 días estuve dormido en el
cti afectado por una enfermedad renal
crónica a lo que no solo me encontraron
eso sino que un combo tuve el
diagnóstico de un quiste en el cerebro
además un síndrome de melancólico
y un síndrome de lo que me hace tener lo
que se llama el síndrome de piernas
inquietas seguramente en algún momento
ustedes lo escucharon
y estoy ya mi esposa entonces una
diálisis que me estaba haciendo en
suecia
yo sé que de esa situación
estoy otra vez en el mismo en el mismo
centro de diálisis yo sé que esa
situación salí gracias al apoyo de mi
familia
recuerdo y a la imaginación que tenía
pero fundamentalmente a mi actitud
ya el inconsolable inconsolable poder de
poder sentir lo que estaba captando lo
que está emitiendo mi corazón
estoy yo o sea que eso es algo de
actitud está acá soy yo luego una
hemodiálisis
entonces tengo la certeza de que salí de
la situación y hoy puedo estar aquí
frente a todos ustedes por la fuerza de
mi corazón
hace poco en uno de los viajes a
estocolmo
hablando con algunos con algunos suecos
me daba cuenta que los tipos son
demasiado estructurados de hecho
nosotros tenemos ya la idea de que somos
los cálidos y ellos son los fríos este
son absolutamente estructurados
armaditos nada pasa sin ser observado
sin ser visto pero sin embargo con uno
habla con ellos
y te preguntan
qué cómo te estás sintiendo ellos dicen
esta frase que es bastante compleja y ni
siquiera yo que he aprendido algo eso la
puedo decir con certeza qué significa
que está pasando por tu corazón en este
momento
es como si yo les preguntara que están
sintiendo de esta charla en este momento
pero no no desde la cabeza sino que les
estamos viendo en el corazón
esta charla en este momento
para mí eso es realmente emocionante y
es muy muy lindo
y eso me lleva a pensar
que cada una de las decisiones que
nosotros tomamos en tiempo real
se llaman corazonadas
corazonadas
y son las que nos hacen determinar más
del 80% de nuestras decisiones en tiempo
real más del 80% de nuestras decisiones
en tiempo real y nosotros no las
percibimos no nos damos cuenta
y no les hacemos caso
por momentos es como si fuese nos damos
cuenta yo me doy cuenta que por lo menos
cuando estuve internado en el cti
escaneaba mi cuerpo en los momentos
donde no estaba dormido para que estuve
más de 22 días en el cti ies cañada mi
cuerpo y trataba de discernir
que sentía antes corazón o cerebro
corazón y cerebro y les juro que me
costó mucho tiempo poder saber
que el corazón por momentos tenía más
fuerza que el cerebro
y si ustedes tienen algún tipo de duda
con respecto a esto que yo les estoy
comentando y les parece una tontería
les quiero mostrar estas palabras
misericordia
significa la desdicha
del corazón de dicha dos de corazón
discordia es la distancia entre dos
corazones
coraje viene de curas de la palabra
francesa que significa poner el corazón
por delante
incluso una palabra tan fea como
corrupto también tiene incluido en la
parte del corazón esta corporación tiene
incluido en la parte de el corazón y si
yo les pregunto a ustedes cuántas veces
han escuchado ojos que no ven corazón
que no siente
y me partió el corazón incluso hasta hay
una canción no me dejó el corazón
partido
pero nadie habla del cerebro entonces
si aún les quedan más dudas
como se dice aprender de memoria en
inglés
soler my heart
y sabía esto
y si les quedan dudas en francés se dice
tuvieran ustedes yo francés no sé pero
es aprender por el corazón
si será inconmensurable el poder del
corazón
aprender de memoria o aprender algo y yo
primero lo pasan por el corazón hablo de
europa primero lo pasan por el corazón y
sí
les quedan quedan bien quedando más
dudas
les quiero mostrar
lo que para mí es es verdad pero es una
verdad discutible que cualquiera ustedes
lo puedo opinar
europa si todos pensábamos nos encanta
nos parece fabulosa londres parís berlín
si no vamos un poco más lejos japón
tokio hiroshima nos parecen maravillosos
pero quiero recordarles que en el mismo
momento que nosotros salimos campeones
del mundo estas ciudades están
devastadas
y ellos salieron de toda esta situación
de este conflicto y esta angustia de
infraestructura humana y emocional
porque su intelecto estaba perfecto
para poder percibir las señales de su
corazón
estos 13 en alemania hoy si lo ven es
una maravilla
en menos de 70 años hicieron una
maravilla
a mí lo que me abruma es que si nosotros
haber pasado por ninguna de estas
situaciones sin haber tenido ningún tipo
de catástrofe
no podemos salir del daño crónico que
tiene nuestro intelecto
y se nos hace muy difícil
llevar adelante situaciones o llevar
adelante un país
sin haber pasado por este tipo de
conflictos que son devastadores
y realmente me preocupa y sé que es un
proyecto para 30 años no lo vamos a
solucionar en 5 años como propone
cualquier político sino que nos va a
llevar 30 ó 40 años
me pasé una acá les quiero contar sobre
las emociones
estas son seis emociones estas seis
emociones desde que el hombre es hombre
hace más de cuatro millones de años que
el hombre se levantó y comenzó a caminar
siente las mismas emociones miedo ira
tristeza asco sorpresa
estas seis emociones están instaladas en
el hipotálamo el hipotálamo está aquí
este es el cerebro y son las que dominan
más del 80% de nuestras decisiones
más del 80% de nuestras decisiones en
forma de corazonadas
y también lo que me llama a mí la
atención es que si estas seis emociones
han permanecido durante cuatro millones
de años porque nosotros seguimos
haciendo caso a la razón
muchas veces algunos de ustedes habrán
escuchado
frente a alguno de sus proyectos que
tienen encajonado son presentados
completos incompletos esto no va a
funcionar esto no va a salir cuántas
veces lo sintieron cuántas veces lo
vivieron es tomás acordar mucho a la
milonga de borges que dice cuántas veces
los corrimos cuántas veces nos corrieron
porque se habla de esa de esa situación
también osea cuantas veces nosotros nos
hemos enfrentado a determinadas
situaciones y ha sido muy complejo
convencer a alguien porque el proyecto
que nosotros presentemos ya sea como
emprendedores pero ya sé como ser
humanos
está presentado o lo analizan desde la
parte del razonamiento y no desde el
corazón
hoy para que tengamos cierto marco les
quiero proponer hacer un ejercicio
les quiero pedir que pongamos nuestra
mano derecha en el corazón
hagamos apenas unos segundos cerremos
los ojos escuchemos y pensemos en quién
más no se haya hecho sentir en nuestra
vida o quien quisiéramos que esté acá en
este momento junto a nosotros nos avale
cualquier proyecto que estemos teniendo
pensando teniendo nuestro corazón en
nuestra cabeza
unos segundos nada más
esa persona en la que ustedes pensaron
les hablo
a través de corazonadas 70 veces por
minuto no tengo aquí 70 veces por minuto
42 mil veces por hora
cien mil trescientos veces por mes 36
millones 800 mil veces por año
bayas tienen que hacerle caso el corazón
la verdad es que por momentos yo muchas
veces a mí me habían dicho que
que mis proyectos no van a salir yo
estoy acostumbrado a desoír y
[Música]
y siempre me opuse a lo que la gente me
ha planteado y trate de hacer siempre lo
contrario obviamente por mi enfermedad y
por tratarse de recorrer un camino
distinto
pero ahora les quiero dar lo que es la
evidencia científica
el corazón siente un nanosegundo antes
que el cerebro eso es una milmillonésima
vez de un segundo 40 mil
neurotransmisores le envíen una señal
al cerebro y este se detiene a procesar
la información
y la detiene y la detiene y la detiene
yo siempre digo que la frase pensarlo
con la almohada y fatiga se puede llevar
un día dos semanas años
cuando la respuesta ya te la dieron en
un nanosegundo
[Música]
debemos aprovechar esa lo que es ese
primer flash porque ahí está la
respuesta a lo que uno siente no razonar
tanto
y si para muestra basta un botón por
haber desoído por haber creído en lo que
mi corazón me decía
este fue mi primer proyecto conecto
fecal ya lo había mencionado antes
conectó un médico es una plataforma que
coordina diálisis a través de todo el
mundo
y nació de mi propia necesidad
empezamos con 14 centros
12 de argentina uno de brasil y uno de
uruguay
pero uno de brasil y uno de argentina 14
y 12 centros de uruguay
hoy estamos en más de 150 países con
8.000 centros en todo el mundo
mi segundo proyectos emotional skills
and intelligence fue creado en israel es
un mapeo emocional
de la cara de tu interlocutor y sale en
tiempo real la emoción preponderante
y a raíz de eso creamos móvil club que
lo que hace es
informar el estado emocional del
paciente perdóneme porque siempre lo con
pacientes
el estado emocional del conductor en la
vía pública entonces podemos lograr
saber quién está dentro del habitáculo
de la misma manera que cuando uno va
circulando por la calle y se quiero
alejarme de esta persona porque le veo
actitudes demasiado extrañas en el
tránsito es igual la única diferencia
que no lo percibimos no lo sabemos
porque está mente un habitáculo con esto
lo solucionamos
entonces
a mí me gustaría contarles una pequeña
historia íntima
porque yo ya en ese momento cuando les
dije de hacer el ejercicio yo había
pensado en mi padre mi padre era un tipo
que estaba que estaba acostumbrado a eso
y era corresponsal de guerra el tipo no
le creía absolutamente nada y una parte
me en parte me inculcó eso
un día este
agosto del 2017 y ya con mi enfermedad
me llegó el trasplante tan anhelado
me dio a mí y de chico me decía
chiquilín de bachín y nunca supe hasta
el 9 de agosto del 2017 de qué se
trataba
la realidad que me llaman me dicen que
va a venir mi trasplante el 11 de agosto
del 2017 se cumplían 29 años de la
muerte de mi padre
el 9 de agosto me operan
y entre morfina y dolores y no se vayan
a reír pero dolores en mi enfermera
/ dolor / morfín de dolores sentía
dolores iguales pero entre morfín y
dolores
vino gerardo pérez que era mi médico
y acá me traje un vaso de agua porque sé
que voy a contar este medio emocional
y él me dijo
en dos días en 939 agosto en dos días ya
te voy a traer el bandoneón y tuve que
tocar algunas canciones mi única
exigencia era que me tocara algo de
piazzolla
que llegó a las 8 de la mañana me dijo
el mejor lugar para dejar de bandoneones
en el cti lo dejo acá a las seis de la
tarde te voy a tocar el bandoneón
efectivamente las seis de la tarde él
llegó puso su bandoneón sus partituras
su tela se sentó
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como para atrás
si la situación exige
a ésta
se sentó
y entre todas esas partituras
con más o menos 2
ya les dije mi única exigencia de la que
tocar algo de piazzolla y en la garra
una y me dice
yo te voy a tocar un tango que no es tan
conocido pero es muy lindo
y se llama chiquilín de bachín
entonces yo supe que en esa habitación
un hospital de montevideo
en una unidad de cuidados intensivos
estaba mi médico gerardo estaba mi
esposa alejandra
pero revoloteando como un duende también
estaba mi viejo
y él fue el que me dio el ok para poder
seguir con lo que yo tenía pensado y aún
más dios ok cómplice para poder avanzar
mucho más con mis proyectos con mi vida
con mi familia
y con todo lo que se me viniera por
delante
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo hoy sigo diciendo que la emoción de
si la razón justifica
y yo les quiero pedir a partir de hoy
que desoiga mucho más a su razonamiento
que desafía en lo obvio que desafíen el
triste conformismo en que vivimos que
oigan a su corazón
que lo sientan a su corazón
pero desde este escenario de durazno en
el centro del país
les quiero pedir y les quiero rogar que
jamás jamás jamás
vayan en contra un sentimiento
[Aplausos]
ah